Now, since everything is nurtured, then this is an accent.
Like D you would look the way you look because that's genetic. Yeah, of course.
You wouldn't have the Catholic tattoos because that's an old world.
You're going to be more of a Buddhist slash tower. If I do get a tattoo,
it's going to be like a little Chinese symbol or it's going to be like a ladder.
Yeah. That goes to like eternity and towards my heart. But make no mistake.
We're all kind of the same. It's that, that you grew up in Richwood.
You're Ridgewood kid. That's why you say unfortunately,
but if you were from San Francisco, you'd be like, hi, you'd get on stage.
You go. Hi guys.
My name is Chrissy D back in I'm from a Montessori school in the middle of San
Francisco. Let's talk about this golden gate bridge for a second.
It's crazy. Isn't the golden gate bridge. Amazing.
I hate when people come into a door and they say, hi, sir. It's like
[inaudible]. Yeah. And
listen, let me tell you something. Yeah. It tells you in any big city here's gas pipe,
Chrissy day. Yeah. If you're an N you always call gas pipe, but it's his steel
pipe.
Yeah.
If you're in any big city. Okay. Especially New York.
I know we got fans from all over the world. Um, and when,
I mean all over the world, I mean, you know, the tri-state area, you know,
mainly just the five borrows, but, um, yeah. We're like the jerky boys. Yeah.
We got some British fans. We've got Australian fans. We got fans, fans, world,
all over the world, the United States of America. If you're in any big city,
the truth is there's so many people in this city.
I don't need you to be over polite in a store. I don't need you to come.
And like, can I help you with anything? And you're framing everything on King.
And he ran it. Just shut the up. If I need something, I'll find the cause.
Guess what? I wouldn't be able to survive 34 years in New York city.
If I didn't know if I didn't know where to go to get what I want.
I don't need you in a 10 by 10 foot store to tell me where the coffee
is. I know where the coffee is, because guess what? The science is coffee.
And that was steel pipe. Chris.
Yeah. It's just.
Just the hypocrisy of people being nice.
Like when you call someone and Verizon and like anything,
is there anything else I can help you with any it's like,
I was just on the phone with you for three and a half hours. Yeah.
Don't you think if there was something else I would've told you,
stop just being a robot and let's be real. You. Call me. Okay. I'm good.
You asked me for help. I'm gonna help you.
I'm not going to suck your Dick to try to. You know, it's like, shut up lady.
Just let me move around the store, please. And you know,
when anybody's sneaker stores calling [inaudible]
, it's like, you know what? I was going to buy something. But now the fact that you just invaded my personal space, I'm either going to not get anything. I'm going to steal something. That's what it is. Steel pipe,
Chrissy.
Oh, dang.
When you go into a sneaker store and they like,
kind of hover over your shoulder, that's the worst. That's my least favorite.
So he's some Indian dude,
because a lot of those stores are owned by Indian guys. Just say, buddy,
you need anything, buddy? I'm like, come on, man. Just let me do it.
You don't need to sell me on anything. I just hate the phoniness of everything.
I really hate it all. it. I hate it all. We can't.
That's why you can't have power. We cannot do it. No,
I don't want, listen. I know I get rageful, but I can step back with it.
And I'm pretty much a nice kid and I am deep down a very gay kid,
so I don't want to hurt anything. And I want to just, you know,
I want to paint and I, cause to be honest with you,
I just want to live in an empire where it's okay for me to,
for guys to swing around. And I could just grab a few socket if I want to. If I,
you know, whatever I want to do, want to put a finger on the button,
it just doesn't matter. And there's no judgment. I can just suck a Dick.
That's the empire I want. And I, you know what I mean?
I just want to eat sweets and listen to Whitney. That's just what I want to do.
And also play basketball. I want, you know,
I do like that and talk about state capitals. That's all I want to do.
But the truth of the matter is make no mistake, make no mistake,
hashtag MNM, mega tech.
If I was given absolute power,
I would 100% lose it quickly and burn the empire down.
But out of kindness and goodness, because I would just, you know,
somebody would be able to manipulate me and tell me that, you know,
and this I should,
I should go alone to this other far away nation because you know,
they have Nutella there and they have, you know, um, um,
all different kinds of Puerto Rican men and women that I would think are hot and
they play Whitney Houston on repeat black and white cook is set up.
Every everybody's are made of black and white cookies.
You could chew off other people's nails, chew off other people. Yeah,
you can text. Do whatever you want that.
Just give you new thumbs every time your thumbs fall off from texting too much.
You can just do that. You're allowed to text and drive and do whatever you want.
And I would go alone. You would say the only, the only catches though,
you can't bring your personal bodyguard. You have to come alone.
And then as soon as I stepped foot off my country,
I would be beheaded and lose power. That's me.
So I would lose it either way now. Yonis, AKA,
Freddie Fetter, cheese, AKA the robo cheese, AKA, um, Katie Lang,
before you continue, can I just say something real quick? Yeah.
You got a strong jawline. Yeah. I would look at you. I'm like, yo,
you look like the cartoon American dad. Yeah,
but you got a strong jawline because then I got,
like mom, like the mom from Bobby's. No, when you got a jaw line like that,
but I got supersedes all the other jello you got going on. Yeah.
But make them steak. I do got mashed potato,
but I am distracted by a strong Christopher Reeves. Superman, American dad.
jawline. Yeah. No, that's me with absolute power.
Yanas Papas with absolute power. Make no mistake.
I know is at a very deep, personal level.
And listen to me when I tell you this,
he is inherently evil, an evil, and the only reason.
And he has a mean streak and the only reason he doesn't kill
Bighead and drink the blood of anybody that crosses him.
It's because his fear of imprisonment and, and, and,
and the only reason why he's scared of going to prison is then because he can't
read router's news sources,
but that's the only reason he's scared is because then he can't read blogs and
he can't. I think they, I love it. You called it ruder is like,
like it's the plumbing company, right? Or routers Reuters, Reuters.
Sometimes you trip over your own trash. Yeah. So,
because he doesn't have access to the New York times and different articles and
different, um, kind of funkshway sites, he would not want to go to prison.
And that's the only reason why that's the only thing that would be if you told
him that, that I can,
you can get the New York times and you can watch CNN on repeat,
and he can jerk off to all Wolf blitzers and Anderson Cooper's, you know,
magical points that they make. And you know, Megan Kelly, and he can,
if you told him that he could rub his transplants to all those liberal sites,
he would do it. And he would go to, and he would have no fear.
So it's a good thing that he's not allowed to watch and read those liberal sites
in prison or else he would go. But if we gave you honest power, no matter,
he would start to concoct things up in his head and he would start to,
if you cross him, you would be beheaded,
but you wouldn't even know BB headed quickly. You would be beheaded slowly,
depending on who you are,
you would take a piece of your service vertebrae one by one,
you have seven cervical vertebrae in your head that connect your head to your
neck. He would cut one out day by day. That's a good idea. Just keep you alive.
What he would also do is because make no mistake.
What he Yonis has Yonis feels that, um,
16 year old girls are fair play, so
helper, whatever. He says something so wild. He's trying to send me to prison.
You just Schwank shrink mission and go make sure you rate, review us,
subscribe, uh, turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys,
where things get really wild.